when people are really really
vulnerable i was talking with someone a
couple of days ago and
reminded them that martin luther king
jr's mother
uh was shot in church
and when we have these
symbols of hate
these white supremacists they tend
go to uh churches burn down the churches
this gentleman researched
history went out to the most historic
african-american church
if people can't be saved in bible study
then they cannot be safe anywhere and
what we had here
was a young man who had no business
having a gun was able to get a gun
because strong information was keyed in
now i will always believe
that he knew the law well enough to
intentionally give wrong information
and by the time they found the right
information he had the gun
that's all we're doing here is saying
give officials time
to do the background check and then
if you pass muster get the gun
and i want to thank those who have been
involved in
bringing this bill to the floor and i
hope
that once again as we did before we can
have
bipolar support to get it done
and i'm so glad that on the other side
of our senator blumenthal
has agreed to sponsor this bill in the
senate
and he and i did a joint session with
the widow of the pastor of emmanuel
church
on yesterday and i'm so pleased to
present them to you now senator blunetta
thank you whip clyburn uh i am really
honored to be here
madam speaker thank you for your
leadership to mike thompson and lucy
mcbath and sheila jackson we thank you
for
your extraordinary courage um
and thanks as well to my great colleague
chris murphy he and i have been a team
on this issue
since his election the senate and sandy
hook
you know listening to uh jim clyburn on
the floor yesterday i was so moved
because
clearly nine people would be alive today
literally nine people members of that
congregation would be
almost certainly alive today if that
killer had not taken advantage
of the charleston loophole a glaring gap
in our laws there is no reason
that people should not wait
a day or two or three to buy a gun
so that a check can be done on them
and there is a principle
at work here the
support for universal background checks
is nearly universal
almost everybody in the country
including gun owners nra members
want and the
principle should be no check
no sale no check no gun
that's the way to make america safer and
i think with the leadership of our great
leader senator schumer
we have a real opportunity to make
history here i'm asked often
what has changed since
sandy hook we have a growing
grassroots political movement
with leaders at the local level changing
history and we have house members who
have run on this
issue who have not just answered
questions they've made it a priority
and so i think the implosion of the nra
the growing support among
the american people and the
inevitability of increased support
gives us an opportunity we've haven't
had before
uh we need not only background checks
and closing the charleston loophole
but also emergency risk protection
orders
safe storage ethan's law repeal of placa
a number of measures that provide
a comprehensive solution there's no
single cure
but i think we can do it with the kind
of support that we're seeing this
morning
and i'm very pleased now and honored to
introduce uh one of the
true champions of uh
gun violence protection or do you want
to go
uh my my mentor and model and leader
senator schumer of new york
okay thank you everybody and it's great
to be here i want to thank
our great speaker speaker pelosi all of
my colleagues in the house and senate
who have played such
instrumental roles in this so important
an
issue and i particularly want to thank
the survivors and the families of the
victims and so many
who have that horrible hole in their
heart because they lost someone to gun
violence so many children
children on our streets gone and yet
these advocates
light a candle every day that's what the
bible tells us is the saintly and noble
thing to do
instead of just cursing the darkness and
i thank them as well
this issue is very important to me as
you those of you been around a while
know
i was the author of the brady law back
in 1994
in the house of representatives and we
passed it
and there are literally so many
you could probably say certainly
hundreds of thousands maybe millions of
people
walking the streets today because we
passed that law
would be dead he'd be dead
but when we passed the law it had
little did we know it had some loopholes
in it that we didn't know at the time
we didn't know there'd be an internet so
we didn't prohibit internet sales
without a background check and to get
the last few votes just a little history
a couple of our members from more
moderate states said just exclude gun
shows
don't put them in because in those days
actually gun shows weren't much they
were places where you showed your 1939
derringer off
and of course the nra and the gun
merchants and the merchants of death
started using the gun shows as a way to
get around the law
so hr 8 closes these loopholes
a universal background check it is
desperately needed
and the house of course has had the good
sense to pass this three times
twice twice twice after today
twice after today we'll have the good
sense to have passed this bill twice
and in the past when they sent it over
to us last time
it went into mitch mcconnell's
legislative graveyard
the legislative graveyard is over h.r
eight will be on the floor of the senate
and we will see where
everybody stands no more
hopes and prayers thoughts and prayers a
vote is what we need
a vote not thoughts and prayers and we
will see where people stand
and maybe we'll get the votes and if we
don't we'll come together as a caucus
and figure out
how we're going to get this done because
we have to get it done
for the lives of the american people
for the safety of our streets and
particularly for our young kids so many
of whom
in my state and all the states represent
mine and jerry state
and all the states represented here
whose lives are taken at such tender
ages
because of gun violence and guns
uh senator durbin will be holding
hearings
and we are shining the spotlight on this
issue
we are going to win on this issue the
american people i'm sure it's been
mentioned
are overwhelmingly like 90
on our side so i thank the house for
having this event but more importantly
for passing the bill today
and now we will focus on getting it
through the senate you're here
who am i supposed to call him and now
my dear dear friend of since
i knew him before he was an assemblyman
and he was a district leader a
powerful district leader on the west
side of manhattan
when he was about 19 years old and just
got out of stuyvesant high school
jerry knapp
thank you very much chuck i want to
begin by thanking uh
representative mike thompson and the
distinguished majority whip jim clyburn
for their leadership in introducing
these two important gun safety bills
i also want to take thank the speaker
and the rest of the democratic
leadership for their support
in bringing this legislation to the
floor
more than once since the house passed
these bills more than two years ago
an estimated 80 000 people 80 000 people
have lost their lives to gun violence
every day that we do not act is another
day that families will mourn the loss of
a loved one
every day that we do not act is another
day that our homes
our streets our schools and even our
houses of worship
are at stake because are less safe
rather because
dangerous weapons are in the hands of
people who should not
legally be permitted to acquire them
every day that we do not act is another
day that the american people
who overwhelmingly support background
checks you've heard the statistics
and closing loopholes in the law those
faith
lose faith in their government's ability
to keep them safe
that's why the house is acting today to
pass both hr 8 and h.r 1446
and that's why we will continue to act
until both of these bills are signed
into law
majority leader schumer as you've heard
and president biden have long been
champions of legislation
to prevent gun violence i know that they
will actively be working to send this
bill to the president's desk
i hope and you just heard senator
schumer say it that the
senate republicans will work with us to
save lives instead of standing in the
way
of this important legislation we cannot
afford to lose another day
and you know we heard today about jim
clyburn spoke eloquently about the
mother ame church but there's also the
tree of life synagogue
there's also parkland high school there
are all these mass shootings
that these two bills will greatly reduce
they're also individual shootings not
just mass shootings
individual shootings in new york we have
very good gun safety laws
but we cannot enforce them over the
borders from states that do not have
good gun safety laws these two bills
will stop that problem
so it will save these two bills will
save
thousands and thousands and thousands of
lives every year
and for that we have a moral duty to
pass it
we have a political duty to pass it
given the polling
and if republicans stand in the way
they'll pay a price both morally
and politically and now it's my
privilege to introduce one of the
leaders
in this fight in the senate senator
chris murphy
this is somebody else it's somebody
else's
sheila jackson lee the the uh
chairperson of the crime subcommittee in
in in our judiciary committee thank you
thank you so very much the american
people have spoken
and i'm so grateful that they've spoken
and our speaker of speaker pelosi
has never stopped listening to the
american people senator schumer has
never stopped listening to the american
people
and we have gathered together
to benefit from the leadership of
chairman thompson
whip clyburn senator murphy senator
bloomingthal and our conscience
congresswoman macbeth who i have the
privilege of serving with on the house
judiciary committee
the precious right of the bill of rights
embedded in the constitution
is loved by all americans and so as
both speaker pelosi and chairman
thompson
and senator schumer said we're getting a
vote
on the preciousness of the american
people's rights
embedded in the constitution nothing in
h.r 8 or h.r
1446 violates any part of the bill of
rights
it does not violate the first amendment
it does not violate the right to due
process and it does not violate
the second amendment nothing in the
second amendment suggests that we cannot
regulate
and provide safety for the american
people
nothing in the supreme court cases like
heller says that
so we are on the right side of the
constitution
and the right side of history and the
right side of the american people who
are pleading
for their lives in
our time it cost
448 thousand dollars for every
homicide incident that results
in medical care or court cases
in addition let me just say that i came
here
and some of you may have gone down
memory lane just as
columbine was taking place what happened
in columbine shocked
america maybe we don't remember right
before the turn of the century 2000
in that case a friend of the boys that
killed all of those students
went to a gun show and bought a carbine
and two shotguns i'll never forget it
that speaker there was a columbine task
force and i was on it we thought
that this would be the beginning and the
end and never have the opportunity
to see that again but it did occur over
and over again
so i'm very grateful that hr 8 uh is
four corners ready to go and h.r 1446
will say that you can pray in your
church and you should not have
the violence of a killer like dylann
roof come
because the background check was not
done
this is a important statement let us
celebrate a vote in the house today
and yes a vote in the senate and a
signature by the president of the united
states
thank you all very much for any
questions
[Music]
they're going to take it up it's going
to have its day and uh if the
republicans do
can you imagine the republicans standing
in opposition to 90 percent of the
american people
but if they do um as the senator schumer
said there's
other options that they will that they
will pursue
and we want to speak specifically
um you know uh this is an idea whose
time has come
we had a majority of votes for a
background check measure in the wake of
sandy hook
when it failed the cry from the gallery
was
shame on you if the republicans
vote against it and there will be a vote
they will pay a price politically
because
as the house members have shown very
courageously by running on this
issue people are not only
supportive they're willing to vote
based on this issue so this is going to
be front and center
and uh you know i think what's also
changed is we now have a president
who can put pressure on
our colleagues and i'm hoping that
uh we'll see that
listen mitch mcconnell spent the last
five years trying to avoid a vote on
background checks because he chose the
nra
um you know his members have expressed
to me over the past
several years that they want to get
right on this issue
and so i don't think we should accept
that there
aren't 60 votes in the senate for
universal background checks so much has
changed
the political power of the anti-gun
violence
movement is infinitely stronger
the nra is a shell of itself
and so i've had a lot of republican
members come to me and express
their willingness to take a new look um
if this bill's on the floor
with 90 public support with the power of
the anti-gun violence movement behind it
i don't think we should
um we should be confident in the fact
that there won't be
republicans who don't want to litigate
this issue election after election
yes senator schumer seemed to say i know
he's not here but
that there would be a vote on the house
bill
and see where everyone stands and if it
fails he'd then
figure something out so are any sort of
this is for the senators i suppose any
sort of bipartisan
discussions happening because when
manchin and toomey got two votes
previously there were four republicans
both times only two of those remain in
the senate
so our mansion and two me on board can
you just talk a little bit about the
process again i just i just think we are
living in a different world
than 2013. uh so much has changed the
politics around this are fundamentally
different
i i think you know senator bloomball i
should leave it to senator schumer to
talk about the floor
uh schedule um i i just think that you
can't compare
2013 to 2021 i think there are a lot of
republican senators
that are thinking about voting for a
proposal that allows them to get right
on this
on this issue thank you i'm going to ask
our colleague
of congresswoman macbeth to close this
out please
well i am just completely grateful
for the all of the hard work and for
all of the effort that has been placed
into making this happen today and i
would just like to
take my hat off for a moment the hat
that i wear as a
member of the united states house of
representatives
and to thank each and every one of my
colleagues
and leadership
as a mother lost her child to the very
gun violence that every one of us has
been fighting for
so hard to eradicate speaker i want to
thank you
thompson thank you for allowing me to be
a part of championing this
life-saving legislation
rob clyburn i spent time with you
i came down to charleston after emmanuel
and i'm more grateful to be able to help
you pass this legislation
because no one deserves the kind of pain
and anguish
that people are suffering especially
those that have
come to god and sat in church and lost
their lives
senator blumenthauer senator murphy
chairman nataler sheila
thank you you have been championing this
legislation long before
i got here and all the times that i sat
in committee hearings waiting for this
legislation to pass
and watching you time and time and time
again put forth amendments that were
shot down for this moment to be able to
be here with you
thank you for that and as a mother as a
survivor we
thank you there's so many of us
survivors and family members that have
lost our loved ones that have been
waiting and waiting and waiting and
today
we have the real possibility to make a
difference and save lives
so i thank you on behalf of all the
organizations
all the leaders all the front-line
volunteers that have been
championing for this moment thank you
thank you all very much
thank you
thank you
yes
you